welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast my name is Eric Trexler I am the
special temporary primary host of the
show but for today's episode I wanted to
mix things up a little bit and I want to
have a co-host so I've invited Greg
Knuckles he is currently the permanent
guest co-host for the time being Greg
thanks for joining me thanks for having
me on how you doing today doing well how
are you I'm doing great it's cold out
now I love my cold weather very exciting
times that uh that makes one of us but
I'm glad you're happy what's your ideal
temperature just perfect day perfect
weather what does it look like uh oh man
anywhere between like
65 and 95. that's such a generous range
yeah that's kind of my ideal temperature
range you live in the right spot then
that works I do yeah yeah yeah yeah I
think mine's about 20. I like 20
Fahrenheit okay yeah that that's fair
um I I think if I lived in a place that
got more than like
10 20 degree days over the course of a
year I I would just leave like I can't I
can't do that yeah uh my girlfriend as
you know uh not very fond of cold
weather but every year I drag her to the
mountains for a little ski trip and this
past year it got to like minus seven and
uh I think she had second thoughts but
the thing is once you're there there's
no going back
yeah yeah I think that uh I I think it's
unnatural I think it's I think it's an
affront to the Natural order uh Humanity
evolved in Africa and
every every place that we spread that is
further from there especially latitude
wise
um I I just think it's I just think it's
a bad move it ain't right um we don't
have we don't have enough hair we don't
have the blubber we don't we clear
humans clearly don't have the
physiological adaptations necessary to
survive in those conditions and like
yeah sure whatever like we're smart we
can make clothing we can make fire
shelter whatever to to be able to
technically survive in places that were
not physiologically adapted for but like
you know so someone can be like ah I I
love the weather in Boston or whatever
but like no you don't like that's that's
Stockholm syndrome it's like we can live
underwater more or less indefinitely in
submarines and I think if someone was
born on a submarine they might say you
know what I don't really like seeing the
sun like that's that's bad that's not
too bright that's not what I'm into but
no like that's completely unnatural uh
hot weather is is what humans were meant
to live in yeah it is funny because like
if you take a undergrad course in
physiology you'll spend like a whole
lecture on uh human adaptations to heat
exposure and then you get to cold
exposure and they're like have you tried
just going somewhere else yeah or like
buying a better jacket that's about it
that's the spectrum of human adaptations
well yeah I mean you've got you've got
shivering uh shivering a modest impact
from a little bit of residual Brown
adipose tissue but yeah I mean compared
to compared to sweating like sweating
versus shivering for dealing with
temperature fluctuations not even not
even a comparison sweating is so sick
like that dissipates so much heat that's
another thing compared to every other
animal like just about every other
animal
humans are are better adapted to deal
with heat exposure like sweating is a
very unique adaptation that is extremely
effective yeah
um
yeah we're not we're not supposed to go
to cold places that is that is my hot
take and I'm sticking by it also I mean
like when you get cold enough another
adaptation is just your your body
diverts more blood to your core to like
make sure your organs stay heated and
whatnot yeah what does that lead to
frostbite your body's telling you like
I'm so poorly adapted to the cold you're
gonna lose a finger to learn this lesson
and then hopefully you leave and go
somewhere warmer
um yeah no I'm I'm a I'm a warm weather
guy yeah hey that that makes sense
um so we have some questions to answer
this is gonna be a question and answer
episode but before we get to that uh you
know there's people out there who enjoy
the show and they want to support it so
there are many ways you could do that uh
you could like rate or subscribe
wherever you get the show uh you could
sign up for our email newsletter we send
out nice research updates every
Wednesday uh so you go to
strongerbyscience.com newsletter and get
some really nice research related
information in your inbox every single
week if you're looking for a virtual
coach online coaching we offer that at
strongerbyscience.com coaching if you
want to get a discount on your
supplements there's one place to do that
you go to bulksupplements.com
you use the code SBS pod you get a five
percent discount I actually did that the
other day I'm uh I had been getting like
a ready to drink protein beverage which
was like pea based but I've decided I'm
going to try to get more creative with
it and mix I got a pea protein rice
protein and soy protein I'm gonna put it
all together into a big you know Dr
trexler's plant-based mix and uh we'll
see how it goes I hope everything mixes
well very on the financial side of
things just think about here's a little
bit of fomo for the audience if you
would have taken the money that you
saved with that five percent discount
buying supplements at
bulksupplements.com with code SBS POD at
checkout if you would have taken those
savings and invested them into put
options on FTX you would be a
billionaire right now so you know uh
just use that discount code at checkout
take your savings every every crypto
related thing that seems here's a here's
a good Stronger by science podcast rule
for the audience any crypto thing that
might go through through your head for
half a second I think this might be a
scam guess what it's always a scam a
hundred percent of the time so yeah just
just try to find a way to to short those
things and
you know you only need them to hit every
so often but yeah you can turn you can
turn five dollars in in supplement
savings into like probably 30 40 million
if you just bet against every crypto
thing that seems like it might be a scam
like it will pay off yeah I think so we
have all of our disclaimers on the show
about not being doctors and all that
stuff
um I've seen some people who do
Financial advice and they say by the way
I'm not a financial advisor don't uh
don't take this advice I don't really
know how those disclaimer works but uh
worth mentioning I don't think that you
are a licensed professional in the field
of Finance uh just putting that out
there but no I I click on too many
things about
um
like
investing and things like that on
Instagram and dude I get the best posts
in my newsfeed like I get so many things
that are like hey did you know that if
you invested 40 Grand in the initial IPO
for Walmart you'd have a lot of money
and it's like yeah I knew that I didn't
need this post but I think looking at
dumb Financial posts on Instagram that
present themselves as insightful and
smart might be my third or fourth
favorite hobby nice and the crypto is
just crypto on Instagram is the best so
highly recommend that but anyway back to
uh Shilling all of our products uh big
news this week so this episode is going
up on the 21st of November and everyone
knows what that is that is the first day
of Our Big Black Friday sale for the
mass research review so best prices of
the Year big discounts on all mass
subscriptions so we've got monthly
yearly or lifetime subscriptions they're
all on sale uh that sale Begins the 21st
of November and it ends on the 28th of
November and proceeds do go to charity
so this year we're donating to a charity
that provides hunger relief we're
donating basically to a big food bank
charity to make sure that people get fed
during the holidays which is always good
uh so uh basically the amount that goes
uh to charity is like uh your first the
first month of your subscription or if
you do a yearly or a lifetime
subscription it's that same amount I I
think it comes out to like 21 or
something out of those so um the sale
does benefit uh charity and it's a
really good cause and I would say it's a
really good product too
uh and then finally if you want to
support us you can check out macro
factor that is the diet app that we
co-created with a really talented team
of developers we do offer a free trial
for that uh I know everyone the week of
Thanksgiving is saying you know what I
want to do right now is begin tracking
but guess what we have a special feature
within macro factor for tracking your
Thanksgiving meal we've talked about it
on the show you literally open it up you
tap the little microphone button on your
keyboard you say Thanksgiving dinner and
boom it brings up a pretty good
representative Thanksgiving dinner so
all of our folks who are tracking with
macro Factor Thanksgiving is going to be
a little bit less stressful for those
who choose to track that day uh anything
else are we good to go here I think
we're good to go all right so let's move
on to some questions and some answers uh
first one really quick one from Deborah
the question is is there any issue in
approaching a minimum dietary fat Target
as a weekly minimum rather than a daily
minimum so for example uh you know if
you go to Stronger by science.com diet
uh I talk all about you know how I would
go about putting together a diet there's
a little formula about how to calculate
your kind of bare minimum fat intake
that I would personally feel comfortable
with
admittedly that is a gray area in the
literature trying to find a really solid
evidence-based minimum fat Target is
actually a lot harder than you would
expect the literature is surprisingly
unclear about that
um so uh but anyway so we've got that
formula in there and people have
wondered you know much like this
question asks do you have to hit you
know that minimum fat Target every
single day of the week or do you want to
just make sure that throughout the
entire week on average you're getting at
least that amount that amount per day so
is it a daily thing or just averaging it
out over the week and I would say when
it comes to a fat intake averaging out
over the week shouldn't be a big problem
so like let's say for example your
absolute bare minimum for fat is 35
maybe you have a day in there where
I would never do this just because like
getting really really low fat intake you
have to work pretty hard like fat Finds
Its way into most diets yeah um so you
have to you have to work pretty hard to
avoid fat if we're talking about on the
scale of like 15 or 20 grams a day right
so but just hypothetical example
your daily fat minimum is like 35 grams
a day or 40 grams a day one day somehow
you only get 20 probably not a big deal
you make up for it over the rest of the
week and average out at least 35 grams
per day over the course of the whole
week that should be totally fine what
we're trying to do with fat is make sure
that we're typically getting in the
essential fatty acids that we need want
to make sure that we're getting enough
fat to just support basic stuff like
cell membrane Integrity hormone
production things like that and we also
want to facilitate the absorption of fat
soluble vitamins but the thing about fat
soluble vitamins is yeah having some
dietary fat helps you absorb them but we
also tend to retain them for a while
like it's not like a water-soluble
vitamin where it goes in it goes out and
you kind of have to replenish it on a
very very frequent basis fat soluble
vitamins we can store them in tissues
pretty well and so if if there's a you
know maybe a little bit less absorption
from day to day because your fat intake
is super super super low uh overall
shouldn't be a problem yeah all right
moving on to the next one here this is
from Alexander this is for both of us
this is one of the ones that we both
picked out uh in the various threads
here and by the way if you're listening
to a q a episode you're saying hey I
have questions how do I submit them uh
in the stronger by science Facebook
group it's called The Stronger by
science community and then in the
stronger by science subreddit uh when
we're about to do a q a episode we just
kind of make a little thread and people
can post questions in there so this one
from Alexander uh are we planning on
competing again power lifting natural
bodybuilding basketball paddle board
completely different sport natural
classic bodybuilding
um uh if so how are we progressing
toward these competitive uh Ambitions
and if not what's the thought process
behind that choice uh I've talked a lot
why don't you take this one sure yeah so
um
I I feel like the operative word in this
question is plan uh and
I don't have any any plans but I'm sure
I'm sure I'll find myself competing in
something again at some point
um the issue for me is I'm
a hyper competitive person and I
struggle with competing in a healthy way
uh if I if I'm doing something to like
if I'm trying to compete in something
like I'm I'm playing for keeps like I I
want to beat everyone
um
and so like if if I allow myself to get
in like a really competitive mindset
around a particular Pursuit I have
um
instead of instead of like whatever
training uh that that contributes to
that competitive thing instead of it
being something that's fun and good for
stress relief and meshes well with the
rest of my lifestyle whatever
um no like it doesn't work like that I
take it extremely seriously
um if I have a bad training session it's
not like oh well I still got to the gym
got some work in it was fun it's like no
I have I have a meet in 10 weeks and I
only have like 40 training sessions left
and one of them just sucked so like two
and a half percent of the training I
have left leading into this meet went
poorly and so now I'm gonna be in a bad
mood the rest of the day
um which you know that's not how I want
my training to be right now and also
like
uh yeah like a in terms of mental space
like there's a lot of stuff going on in
my life right now a lot of stuff going
on with business and like I need some
some mental resources to be able to
devote to those things but no like if if
I've registered for a competition
certainly
um as few things as possible penetrate
the awareness of my conscious mind until
that competition is done like I I'm
when I decide I'm going to compete in
something I pursue it with an extremely
single-minded Focus which is completely
incompatible with my life right now and
what I what I need to get out of
exercise right now
um so yeah like I'm I'm sure I will find
myself competing in something again at
some point in the future but nothing
that that one would term a plan so
that's like I I assume once I get under
200 like I'll I'll probably uh find a
power lifting meet to do it 198 and just
try to try to hit a big total there
um but yeah like nothing nothing
imminent yeah
so this is kind of interesting though
but
they're so far to my knowledge no one
has ever broken the two-hour Marathon
barrier which I find to be both sad and
pathetic well with with a with an
asterisk yeah
have people done it uh yeah Kip choge
went like an hour 59 40 or something
when did that happen because the
breaking 2 project didn't work
yeah it was like a year after that oh
well anyway
someone needs to do it the right way and
I'm going to take that burden upon
myself
um now I think
I'm kind of like you but I think in
terms of like if I decide to to compete
I kind of put that as the absolute top
priority I would be interested to see if
I have the capability of competing in a
different way uh and I think I do but
I've never tried it the last time I
competed I was in a very very different
headspace and you know really into the
tunnel vision on competition
um so much like yourself I don't have
any specific plans to compete but I do
vaguely kind of assume that I will
compete in something in the future right
now I'm leaning toward Marathon uh as
the next thing I would do
and uh obviously I ran into some injury
related issues I in like that was to be
expected I was doing more running to
avoid or kind of work around a hip issue
and what do you know hips also run I
didn't know that uh so it didn't really
work out that way the the same injury
kind of impaired my ability to train for
that but I will say
make it a lot of progress uh hip is
feeling as good as it's felt in a long
time uh training harder than I have
probably in the last few years like
really hitting the gym hard lately
lifting only no running at the moment
but I I think marathon is is going to be
in the plans and I think it'll be a
really fun thing and I think because I'm
a novice at it I think I'll be able to
compete without having to adopt that
really really narrow kind of tunnel
vision Focus which would probably be a
healthier way to compete compared to
compared to the Past
um actually funny story about this
though uh let's see this this episode's
going up on the 21st but today is the
14th right
so there was a marathon locally like two
weeks ago maybe a week and a half or
something uh
I almost entered it like four days
before
and I haven't run in a very long time uh
no not four days seven days before and
for some reason something came over me
and I was like I'm gonna do this
Marathon dude but I haven't run in a
very long time so my plan was I was
gonna wake up one week before it go for
a jog and just say how'd that feel and
if it felt good I was going to enter the
marathon one week after if it felt bad I
was gonna abstain ultimately I woke up
and it was rainy and I was like ah I
don't want to run today so I didn't so I
canceled the experiment but yeah
something weird came over me and I was
like I want to do this and then one of
the biggest things that convinced me not
to is just that it coincided with like a
time where like when we're doing the
most of our Mass writing I was like dude
if I'm like bedridden from severe leg
soreness that's not going to be a good
time for me to be dealing with that so
ultimately my uh I probably made the
right decision to not dive into that
totally untrained but uh I think that's
gonna happen within the next two years
that's what I guess sounds good uh but I
am going to train for it I'm not just
gonna wake up and uh looks like there's
a marathon in town
uh all right a quick one I want to
answer here uh just to provide some
utility to the very good listeners at
home uh Nicole has a question uh that I
think is gonna
um I think a lot of people have interest
in this so uh the question is about
music as a performance enhancer
curiosity about if uh it works and if so
why it works uh and so the question was
asked because I've taught I've taught
I've touched on some psychology related
topics lately and so Nicole thought
maybe I looked into this I personally
haven't looked into this literature too
much but our good friend Dr Mike zordos
has looked into it he's actually
reviewed at least two studies in the
mass research review about music and
performance and by the way if you
subscribe to mass during the Black
Friday sale you get access to the entire
Archive of past articles videos audio
discussions Etc so more content than you
could ever hope to work your way through
um
so zordos has reviewed a couple of these
studies and generally speaking it seems
that when you select music that you
enjoy and has the right beats per minute
and it has the right Vibes you know when
you're able to select a type of music
that really helps you get amped up the
natural result of that is heightened
arousal and that can lead into greater
self-reported levels of motivation and
it can also potentially shift your
attentional your attentional focus a
little bit from internal factors like
fatigue and the subjective like ow my
biceps are burning I want to stop this
set might shift it more to external
factors where you're just kind of
focusing more on the Good Vibes and the
music and it allows you to push through
some of that fatigue to some extent but
there are two important points to
consider on this topic uh when people
are able to select their own preferred
music in research studies it seems to
work better than when they are kind of
given a non-preferred type of music so
you want to make sure that you're
picking absolute bangers that truly do
slap to use some of your vernacular
there another thing is that more arousal
is not always better you know when it
comes to this kind of psychological
arousal during exercise it's largely
agreed that there is a bit of a u-shape
or an inverted u-shaped pattern where
very low arousal is associated with
relatively poor performance and way too
much arousal in some types of tasks can
be associated with actually impaired
performance so you want to find yourself
in that middle ground where you are
amped up enough to really tap into that
motivation and that energy and
excitement about what you're doing but
you don't want to be so like overwhelmed
with with being like hyper stimulated
and Hyper aroused that you're not really
able to focus on the execution of what
you're doing uh anything to add there
yeah the the arousal curve thing like
one one thing to note about that is it
does depend to some extent on the
complexity of the task at hand yeah
um like how how technically demanding it
is how much you have to focus on it so
you know if if you wanted to exert as
much force as possible during like a
maximum isometric knee extension or
something
um I I think that performance arousal
curve is more of just like a straight
line like the more arousal the better
um versus something like a snatch or
like a cleaning jerk you probably like
it is probably more of an inverted uh
for that as well
um so like like anecdotally a lot of
power lifters report like oh yeah like
if I like over height myself for a max
squat
um things might get crazy greater odds
of a misgroove whatever versus a lot of
dead lifters who were just like very
gripping and rip it it's like yeah I'm
gonna put on Rage Against the Machine
Crank It Up to 15 and just yeah you know
so yeah there there's some there's some
Nuance here but for for the most part
like yeah you're you're trying to get
adequately aroused but not over aroused
so you're cranking up Rage Against the
Machine for that big set which song are
you putting on
um
I am personally partial to calm like a
bomb for for a PR track if if I'm going
rage okay I've I've mentioned this
before
um but my in you know you can't do this
for rep max sets because the the perfect
part of it is so short but for like just
a single one rep max just give it
everything I got uh type song uh I put
on Bridge Over Troubled Water by Simon
and Garfunkel and skip to the crescendo
um like you know when when it starts
like when you need a friend Papa and
then like Gonna Get Us with a copyright
you're so close there absolutely not but
yeah then once it once it swells after
that if you have that on with like
really loud but like pretty high quality
speakers it just it gets me just right
and that is that is the best uh PR song
in my opinion I tell you what research
aside research is for nerds who cares uh
but definitely by the research review
but research aside man there's nothing
better than when you walk in to a
training session
and the playlist is just perfect you
know what I mean when it's just right
and sometimes like sometimes it can be
really hard you're in the gym and you're
just like I cannot get the vibe right
today like I you start you start
flipping through totally different
genres of music and you just can't find
the right fit for the the workout and
the mood that you're in and things like
that it's there there's really nothing
better than when it all lines up and
nothing worse than when you're just in a
rut and you're like I can't I can't do
it I can't find the right music it's the
worst no I I agree I agree all right
um
I still remember by the way uh the first
time I ever benched 300 pounds I had uh
I still remember the song uh because it
was a truly euphoric moment I mean 300
pound bench the first time like to me
that was a huge deal uh I was listening
to sleepyhead by Passion Pit very good
one rep max song but the reason it was
euphoric was because that was back when
the original formula Jack 3D oh hell
yeah it was all over the place and so
like
I I was truly experiencing euphoria that
stuff was incredible man uh what a
travesty that that's off the market
absolutely terrible yeah yes
um pre-workouts used to be so much
cooler back in the day yeah yeah now
it's just like oh here's some caffeine
we'll put a little beta alanine in there
make your face tingle it's just not what
it used to be man yeah they they really
crack down on like good stimulants
because they're they're for like a meh
I'd say probably five six years all of
all of the really smart chemists that
worked for the big supplement companies
were just like ooh we found this
loophole if if we essentially make meth
but like it it was essentially like the
designer steroid thing like in in the
old like uh in the old steroid
legislation they were they were
basically like yeah here are the
compounds that are that are banned and
here are their exact chemical structures
and like you can't manufacture use or
sell those and so then you know people
who like like biochemists were like go
well we can we can tweak this one little
thing here and it'll still have the same
effects but skirt the legislation and
then they like Congress realized oh
that's like a pretty big loophole so you
know they kind of wrote it any more
Spirit of the of the law way like yeah
you can't use these drugs or anything
that's like basically these drugs like
you you get it but yeah like like uh
stimulants went through a very similar
thing where folks were like oh well we
could we could like tweak this a little
bit and it's not technically meth
um and then yeah those those loopholes
got closed as well but they're I mean
there for a while like I I understand
why pre-workouts are such like a big
part of gem culture which I don't think
they were really in like the 80s and
like 90s so much I don't know like I I
wasn't in gym culture back then but like
that's like looking at old magazines
like old Fitness content you know I just
don't see advertisements for a bunch of
pre-workouts they they didn't seem to be
a thing but then like they're in the the
early to mid odds into into like the
early 20 teens as well
um I mean there there were pre-workouts
that yeah I I think were essentially
just speed and I think there was an
entire generation of lifters who like
Loki just got addicted to pre-workout uh
like if you're the type of person who
enjoys uppers
um you're like oh yeah like I I work out
because it's healthy definitely not just
as an excuse to to to use more legal
meth
um yeah 400 milligrams of caffeine and
this like slightly legal meth like yeah
it's it's for the health man yeah so
um yeah I I I I strongly believe that
that's one of the reasons why like the
whole concept of pre-workout is just
like so embedded in gym culture at this
point there's a bunch of a bunch of uh
purported Health enthusiasts who are
walking around with the blood pressure
like 180 over 110. yeah you you got like
your eye twitching your your pupils are
the size of dinner plates and it's like
oh yeah this is this is just so I can uh
perform well in my workout to yeah like
you said improve my health yeah oh man
those those were the days and that's the
thing people are gonna especially
younger folks are gonna think that
you're being hyperbolic when you say
like that like structurally they were
awfully close to meth but like I
literally failed an employment uh drug
test for methamphetamine yeah because I
was taking those uh those pre-workouts
and like fortunately it was such a
common thing at the time that we got it
sorted out and they just sent it to a
different lab with more sophisticated
testing but like no you it's not just
like oh there's a possibility you could
have a false positive like it happened
uh to me and many others but yeah it was
very very similar this is I I don't
think these two things are related
except for like the temporal relation
but I mean the the meth crisis in the
U.S did really seem to pick up once they
took all of the good stuff out of the
pre-workouts like I I wonder I wonder if
it's kind of like once they made uh you
know like when they made uh like Oxys
harder to get your hands on and like
harder to use recreationally that's when
a bunch of people started using heroin I
kind of wonder if if a similar thing
happened
for some people once the once the
pre-workouts became less cool I have
absolutely no idea
um I mean I I don't I certainly don't
think it's a primary contributor but
you have to say probably probably
probably
unrelated I I would assume I I would
assume as well uh let's move on let's
move on yeah I've got a question from
Michael about trt or testosterone
replacement therapy uh and the question
is what is the potential impact of trt
on nutrition and training
recommendations particularly for someone
with a physique oriented goal uh first
of all trt is a medical intervention and
therefore any Ambitions or plans related
to trt you should be discussing with a
qualified health care professional uh in
terms of kind of just from a
uh educational perspective uh looking at
you know broadly what what would one
anticipate
um I'm obviously going to defer to Greg
for training stuff but for a nutrition
uh if you're going from a position where
you have clinically low testosterone
say your testosterone is like 200 uh you
know was it deciliters it's it's an
anagrams yeah so let's say your
testosterone's at like 200 nanograms per
deciliter and uh let's say you ramp it
all the way up to 900 via medically
supervised trt
in that situation your your hypertrophy
potential is going to be heightened uh
that is a physiologically meaningful
change in your testosterone level and
what that means is you might be able to
accommodate some modest increases in
protein and calorie intake if we
consider that all other variables are
held constant this is I want to
acknowledge very speculative
um I'm just kind of leaning on intuition
here because I know that there's
basically two schools of thought here
one school of thought is you know you
can actually get away with less protein
because you have this huge robust
increase in the stimulus for muscle
protein synthesis that that the kind of
line of thinking is therefore you don't
need to force your way to muscle growth
through really high protein intakes I
know that some people take that
perspective I don't find that to be
particularly compelling personally
um I think the more likely scenario is
that through the increased stimulus for
muscle protein synthesis through the
testosterone replacement I think it's
very likely that you are now in a
position to more effectively utilize
slightly higher protein intakes and then
of course there's an additional energy
cost of hypertrophy so theoretically a
little bump in calories as well I I
think it basically just elevates the
ceiling of on a per unit time basis how
many new Pro muscle proteins can you
synthesize so of course there's going to
be a stimulus from training a stimulus
from testosterone but then ultimately
you need the raw materials around there
you need to have the dietary protein
coming in for the essential amino acids
that are actually going to be put
together to to make these new muscle
proteins so my intuition I know there's
two different schools of thought I can't
say definitively which one is
scientifically correct but I lean more
on the uh like I've heard some people
who actually say like you should reduce
your protein intake when you get on trt
because you don't need the protein
anymore I find that to be
counterintuitive and I would say you'd
probably I would expect either leave
your protein similar similar or
potentially ramp it up just a little bit
to accommodate the increase in how much
protein synthesis will really be
happening per unit time
um
yeah I think that's probably probably my
two cents on it what do you think about
that logic uh yeah that that that makes
sense to me I was I was going to say
yeah the reason I say that is because
um I've been digging into literature
comparing High versus low protein
targets recently and it seems as if the
the kind of more pronounced bigger
impacts of High versus low protein and a
lot of the studies I'm looking at it
seems to be kind of more
more Amplified or more magnified more uh
you know kind of a larger difference
between high and low in studies where
people are relatively untrained at
Baseline and so they have the capacity
to really pack on more muscle in a short
period of time and some of the studies
with people that are more muscular at
Baseline and kind of higher training
status you're not really seeing as large
a magnitude of effect there so that's
kind of my two cents yeah that makes
sense for for those studies though like
are we talking like a different absolute
magnitude of of effect or a different
relative magnitude of effect different
relative like the impact of having
hybrid not just like more kilograms of
fat-free Mass but like the magnitude of
how much better off with were you with
high versus low I gotcha yeah I gotcha
yeah on on the on the training side of
things
um I I think it's pretty similar
um so like I think presumably you can
probably handle a bit more training
volume probably recover a little bit
better the reason I say probably is I
don't think there's a ton of research on
that
um and I'll readily admit that's that's
just not an area of research I follow
super closely
um
my general perspective on on on trt as
it would be for just about any other
medication is that like
if you're if you're taking a drug for
health benefits like you're taking the
drug for health benefits and whatever
the impact on training is is whatever
the impact on training is
um and I also sort of think that if you
have a generally smart well-designed
training program that uses some sort of
feedback mechanism to regulate loads
regulate volume
um you know maybe you're using rpes
maybe you're using reps in reserve
um maybe it is just more of a subjective
thing like hey like if I still feel good
after three sets I'll do a fourth
whatever like unless you're unless
you're just like rigidly sticking and
adhering to a completely rigid training
program where you have all of the
weights all of the sets uh all of the
Reps laid out weeks in advance with no
ability to deviate from it
um you know as long as there's some
flexibility built in there
uh if trt has a positive effect on how
much training you can handle or how
quickly you adapt to it those uh those
built-in methods for like flexibly
altering your training program should
just take care of it
um so I I probably wouldn't go out of my
way to
prospectively make huge program
adjustments knowing oh I'm going to
start trt next week or whatever
um
but yeah I I mean I I assume just
whatever you're doing that's currently
working it'll probably just make it work
a little bit better yeah and again uh
one thing I I want to mention before we
move on is my answer is pretty
speculative like I I try to make sure
that I tag very clearly my speculation
versus like here is a rock solid
evidence-based answer so uh if people
want to jump in the comments and yell at
me uh I accept that responsibility and I
will take whatever punishment is coming
foreign
Fitness podcast with a steadfast
commitment to traditional Family Values
we know that protecting families is
important right you are Eric but I will
note there are some things that are even
more important than protecting
traditional family values and the moral
fabric of our society that's right Greg
it's important to protect families but
it's even more important to protect
corporate entities that's why I joined
the Advisory board for the Sports
Nutrition Association Along with trusted
Fitness Pros like Danny Lennon and
distrusted arch nemesis like Eric Helms
the Sports Nutrition Association is the
home of Sports Nutrition they are
dedicated to ensuring the sustainable
prosperity of the Sports Nutrition
profession and they offer a unique
Pathway to robust insurance coverage for
your Sports Nutrition business simply
put it's the best way to protect the
corporate entities that are closest to
your heart and I should note if you're
an individual soul rioter providing
Sports nutrition services and not a
corporate entity the Sports Nutrition
Association can help you out as well
that is correct all insurance plans are
handled individually on a case-by-case
basis regardless of how your Sports
Nutrition business is structured but
even if you don't want insurance
coverage sna membership comes with a
bunch of other perks and advantages the
Sports Nutrition Association is the only
Global professional sports body that has
a defined standard for Sports Nutrition
scope of practice for its members this
ensures that members maintain high
standards in their practice so that the
public can always trust in the quality
associated with the services of an
accredited Sports nutritionist through
the Sports Nutrition Association if you
already meet their minimum education
requirements you can become an
accredited Sports nutritionist today if
you don't meet those education
requirements yet you can enroll in the
certificate program in a applied Sports
Nutrition that allows you to become a
provisionally accredited member upon
completion to learn more about the
Sports Nutrition Association head over
to
www.sportsnutritionassociation.com today
today's episode is sponsored by the
Sports Nutrition Association and
stronger by science LLC sincerely
appreciates their support
all right do you have any uh do you have
a question that you want to throw in the
mix here oh I'm good to just keep keep
rolling in the order of the outline cool
uh well I did skip over one so let me
get to that one
um this is just an accountability
exercise basically Michael
I think that's how to pronounce it
um Michael asks if I've thought about
writing a book or article or something
like that about statistics and
methodology and research I'm not sure
who this is directed to
um but I'll answer it because I mean I
hope it's directed to you you know you
know way more about stats than I do yeah
I think this was right after I'd
answered a couple of I think it was a
couple of his questions about statistics
for meta-analysis so I think it was
directed to me but um I kinda like I've
made a lot of progress toward that type
of project uh really leaned into it and
then tabled it for a while
and the the problem is I've talked to
people who write books relatively
frequently and it's something that I'm
gonna have to get over but apparently
it's a common thing that sometimes you
just can't put it down and say like this
is done like it has covered the things
that ought to cover Let It Go and set it
free out into the world I can't quite
get to that point with it because I keep
learning new things and it's really hard
to restrict the scope of that type of
thing because you're like
I mean statistics has been humming along
you know really moving for
yeah it's been picking up a lot over the
last hundred years and even in the last
like 30 there's been a lot of movement
and things are picking up and people are
even picking up old ideas that were
discarded like a hundred years ago and
saying oh actually we should have gone
that way instead yeah there there was
there was a lot of work back in the day
where these very big brain statisticians
would do a bunch of math and be like hey
we hit on this method that should do a
much better job than what we currently
do of analyzing this particular problem
but guess what computers don't exist and
it would take about four months to work
through a problem by hand so let's just
not uh worry about this too much and now
people are looking back through old
papers and being like hey we have
computers now and some of this old [ __ ]
was good and we just forgot about it
because no one could could do it at the
time yeah yeah there were so many
instances where Theory outpaced
computation uh in a way that was just
kind of a dead end because who could
have who could have fathomed that
personal Computing would get to the
point where it is
um but yeah so anyway the the short
version is
it's difficult to say like what is the
scope of this project what statistical
procedures need to be talked about in
depth what methodological considerations
need to be talked about in depth uh
because you know it's it's quite
audacious to say hey I wrote a book
about all research if you read it you'll
be adequately prepared to tackle all of
it so good luck
um yeah it's really tough but I do
expect at some point in my career I will
publish a large thing that involves a
lot of detail about statistics and
methodology
all right
um Greg we're now into your your area of
the um of the outline but you know what
before we do that
there's two kind of like
off topic questions
um that are you know kind of like uh
I guess they're semi on topic but the
type of thing that we might answer in uh
in like a fireside chat why don't we do
one of those and then we'll end this
episode and then we will uh pick back up
next week with more q a that sounds good
to me awesome so this one is is kind of
a big can of worms here
um
we got a question from Edward and the
question is
there's a lot of faulty science out
there for sure
but what is some questionable or
outright incorrect advice or insights
that industry experts or researchers
still circulate
uh so looking at industry experts and
researchers are there any
pieces of advice floating around these
days that seem to be either unreliable
speculative or downright just incorrect
so my short answer to this question
is that I think this is getting worse
and not better
uh maybe I'm falling victim to recency
bias that that's very very possible
but uh I think some of the current stuff
in this vein is just inherently way more
deleterious than it used to be
um because like I I remember when I was
first kind of tapping into the fitness
industry and saying hey what's the
chatter around here and like it would be
stuff like the stuff that comes to mind
for me is like hey you should eat more
frequently to boost your metabolism
does that matter no is it harmful no
it's just annoying it's like yeah you
don't actually need to eat eight times a
day you could just have like three or
four meals a day and you're gonna be
just fine so like that stuff was going
around who's it harming it's
inconvenient at worst right yeah yeah uh
another thing that was going around when
I was getting into was like hey you need
to you really need to hammer carbs
post-workout because like glut4
receptors they're translocated you're
you know you just did three sets of ten
man your glycogen depleted you need to
really carve up and not only that you
need to have this very special type of
carbohydrate that stuff was so overblown
for the general general fitness
population was it necessary no but again
was it harmful like dude you had some
maltodextrin after your workout big deal
not not a big deal but like nowadays
it's like
hey I know your car your cardiologist is
worried about your high LDL but like
dude trust me don't take your medicine
yeah like
that's a fundamentally different type of
thing going around uh and is that the
consensus among industry experts or
researchers no
but are there researchers and Industry
experts saying it there are like there
are now people who are going back and
saying like
ignore your cardiologist's
recommendations uh the the person who's
literally treating you with your entire
medical history in your in their chart
uh there's people saying hey never eat
fiber why like that's a deleterious
thing to recommend to People based on
all the evidence we could lean on uh you
got people talking about like dude uh
don't worry about Sun related like skin
damage don't worry about massive
sunburns as long as you're not eating
seed oils like this is fundamentally
dangerous information
I I mean if we're talking like eh not as
many researchers but like industry
experts I mean there's a there's a
pretty big contingent of just like
full-on anti-vaxxers in the in the
fitness industry now and like yeah
that's that's [ __ ] dangerous yeah I
mean so to me uh
it is getting a lot worse rather than
getting better like the idea like oh we
have the internet now we can robustly
fact check things on the Fly and we're
going to ultimately triangulate toward
only the best ideas let that go that is
not happening at all
um and like right now there's like
people with kind of that take more of
like a biohackery approach and people
that take like a Homeopathy approach
which uh a term I saw the other day was
bromiopathy which was like the
convergence between like Homeopathy and
like Ultra masculinity
um and there's people that are taking
these approaches that are developing
really really big followings with
tremendous amounts of reach I mean far
more than we could ever hope to have and
uh ultimately I understand why that
resonates like there are a lot of people
right now who have huge followings who
are like trust me I'm an expert effort I
lean on the science and the stuff that
they're putting out is fully
unscientific in nature and in some cases
just flatly incorrect but I I understand
why it resonates like I understand why
those followings are so big and it's
because it's um
it is superficially on the surface
embracing science but without all the
difficult messy stuff that makes science
boring and kind of tedious to work
through like so it's taking
um really concise narratives and really
consent internally consistent narratives
at the expense of nuance so like you you
talked about this I think the last time
we recorded where you're putting
together an Instagram post and you're
like there's about six caveats that I
ought to put in here and we do and it
kills the reach of the post it kills the
reach and it makes the comments so much
more annoying yeah and so it's you're
just signing up for punishment when you
do that you're like I could just kind of
commit myself to an internally
consistent Viewpoint build that
narrative and keep going back to that
well and when new research comes along
to support it boom throw it in the pile
when new research comes along that says
hey you should probably add a caveat or
add some Nuance to that narrative throw
it out not interested whatsoever
um and so yeah these narratives that
seem scientific on the surface they are
easier to build easier to digest easier
to circulate But ultimately they lose a
lot of the Nuance that makes the
evidence-based part of the argument
actually based on the evidence like like
you start to
separate from the evidence via
oversimplification
in a way that really blurs that line
between is this still actually
evidence-based when it lacks Nuance to
this degree
um and
you know it kind of makes people feel
good when they see these narratives
because they're like dude no I'm not not
following you know some random jackass
on Twitter I'm not just listening to the
biggest person in the gym I am listening
to a person who promises me that this is
science but the nice thing is it's so
simple and straightforward and concise
and streamlined and internally
consistent and there are never any
complicating factors
you that should make you feel very
uncomfortable yeah when when you are
hearing about science and it feels so
smooth and it goes down easy you're
probably deviating pretty hard from the
science at that point like that should
be kind of a a default red flag that
kind of sets off your your BS detector
now there are some instances where
science does end up being pretty
intuitive so I'm not saying it's uh you
know a hundred percent of the time
you're in a bad spot but man when people
present things that that are just too
internally consistent and smooth and
there's never caveats and there's never
oh by the way it doesn't apply here and
it doesn't apply there
you got to be careful about that stuff
so
a couple things that come to mind for me
uh examples right now of things that
have actually can can I just add one
more thing in terms of in terms of like
broader Dynamics for why that stuff
comes across like seeming so appealing
to so many people yeah so I've been
um
uh so I I was uh I I took I took some
Poli SCI classes in undergrad and I've
I've been uh doing some more reading
about just kind of like General media
literacy and like dynamics that
um like like people who want to use the
media to their own end can use to like
push a particular message and one of the
things that comes up in uh in like
conversation about those things and like
in in research about some of those
things is the idea of uh controlling a
message and and uh controlling the
messaging on an issue and a lot of that
just comes down to
um
consistently messaging about a
particular issue so like if like like
let's say that there's uh some idea like
in like I I don't want to get too
specific on this to make it like too
controversial or whatever but like if
there's so we don't have any reach uh
yeah that's fair but yeah if there's
some sort of controversial topic and
um
like let's say that there's like very
broad scientific consensus that all
leans in one direction to the point
where like it's essentially settled like
you know nothing in science is ever
completely fully settled but you know
like there's there's overwhelming
consensus uh leading in one particular
like like leaning in one particular way
um and like you know maybe there was
like a pretty big public messaging
campaign around whatever topic that was
ah 10 years ago 15 years ago like
whenever it was pretty much figured out
and then uh you know then the experts
are essentially like well okay we've got
this out there now we can kind of rest
on our Laurels
um you know we don't want we don't need
to be running ads on TV uh you know
every single week like during during NFL
games or whatever to like convince
people of this like public health thing
anymore like we've we've done it it's
good
um so then in essentially their seeding
seeding message control to whoever wants
to take up the mantle and talk about
that topic all the time yeah
um so like uh I I do think General
Nutrition stuff is a pretty good example
of this where
like you know like legitimate health
professionals might say oh like try to
watch your calorie intake eat uh five
five servings of fruit and vegetables
per day and uh limit processed meat
intake and like ah you're probably
pretty good and let's make like let's
try to make sure everyone in the general
population hears that message at least
like once every six months or so so it
kind of kind of stays in there but then
you know let's say there's a carnivore
influencer on Instagram who every single
[ __ ] day is gonna post a new post and
like eight news stories about how oh
actually all of those people are full of
[ __ ] and if you want like the best
health uh just eat raw beef for every
meal every day
um at that point if someone follows them
that person is controlling that issue
you know like the the
they're they're not going to get
consistent pushback from the legitimate
authorities in the area and even like I
mean even uh like like other industry
folks who broadly disagree with them
like dude like I I would say this is an
anti-carnivore podcast uh but like we
don't talk about it on every episode
um and certainly you know I'm I'm not
posting anti-carnivore stuff on my
Instagram TL every single day I don't
think I ever have I'm not posting about
it in my stories every single day I
never I don't think I ever have yeah and
so you know essentially even even the
people giving pushback the pushback is
not as consistent as the messaging
itself
um and so yeah like that
essentially Things become things start
feeling more and more inherently true
the more times you encounter them like
that's that that's propaganda 101
essentially and and I don't think that
people pushing sketchy like health and
fitness claims view themselves as
propagandists but like that's that's the
Playbook they're benefiting from
essentially and so like
yeah if you wind up following some of
those folks and they keep they stay on
message they have good message
discipline and they talk about the same
things in the same way day after day
week after week and you encounter that
content
each time you encounter it uh it either
either it turns you off initially and
you're just like no and then every time
you see it it's just more and more
ridiculous and you're like nah that's
silly but if it's like
if it's like a little bit intuitively
appealing the first time each time you
encounter that message it is just like
more and more appealing you've seen it
more it just it feels less Fringe and
more just like a normal part of the
information ecosystem you're in because
it is more a normal part of the
information ecosystem you're in because
you're encountering it all the time
because they're posting about it all the
time and there's not that that
consistent pushback so yeah like there's
um it makes it very understandable that
that folks are uh sucked in by some of
that stuff because uh yeah the folks
pushing those message messages I think
largely unintentionally are just um uh
using the toolkit of propagandists which
unfortunately is uh it works really well
it's very effective yeah I would push
back against one thing there uh you
mentioned that this is an anti-carnivore
podcast
um
I I don't view it that way and I I think
you're kind of oversimplifying the
language like like you said I mean we
don't go out of our way to dunk on the
carnivore diet frequently but we do
vocalize uh a strong opposing
perspective about you know what is the
kind of
healthiest or best health promoting
dietary pattern and the reason I bring
up that distinction is because I
I am increasingly as I get older and age
out of precipitous rate
more interested in being helpful than
correct and I don't want to put out
content that seems
maliciously or mockingly anti-carnivore
uh perhaps I've slipped up in the past
I'm not certain I don't think I've put
out too much of that
but what I would prefer to do is extend
an olive branch and just say Hey listen
you're you're liking the carnivore diet
and presumably that's for some number of
reasons right so maybe you do have some
pretty nasty food allergies or other
types of food related pathologies or
sensitivities and this is just one form
of Extreme Elimination Diet that acutely
has uh put some of those symptoms into
remission
that I I understand that
um and that's uh it's good that the
elimination element of that diet has
been acutely helpful but elimination
diets in the clinical sense are not
long-term Solutions it's it's the first
step and then you start reintroducing
foods from there to see what's going to
be a workable normal dietary pattern for
us to use long term right so I I I'm
what I'm interested in doing moving
forward with carnivore type stuff is
just meeting halfway and saying hey
there there might be a good reason that
you have gravitated toward this this
diet maybe you've really struggled with
satiety in the past and this is a diet
that really helps you better than any
other diet you've tried keep your
calorie intake lower
um or you know maybe
you know you have struggled you know
with Hyper palatable foods and whenever
you eat them it kind of derails your
dietary progress so this you know I've
been trying to embrace the fact that
people who gravitate it and fall in love
with it there may be an underlying
reason that has some some real
legitimacy there but then the question
is well where do we go from here like do
we eat just raw beef for the rest of our
life I would argue there's probably a
better way right and so what I'm
interested in doing moving forward in a
broader sense is saying okay let's let's
meet halfway you like carnivore right
now what if we did kind of like a beat
heavy uh beat heavy a beef heavy
approach to keto right boom First Step
get some fibrous vegetables in the mix
they're fine right and then you say okay
well we're in this like kind of beat
have beef I keep saying beet uh
dissertation research coming back we're
in this kind of be focused keto diet
that has some vegetables mixed in
um maybe we open up and say what are
some different protein and fat sources
that can round this out a little bit
right and then we say okay now we're on
a pretty standard ketogenic diet we've
we started checking some of those boxes
that I mentioned a couple episodes go
and kind of you know broad Strokes what
makes a healthy dietary pattern what if
we bumped from this this now pretty
conventional keto approach into Meet Me
Halfway let's go paleo yeah right what
I'd be interested in is trying to kind
of offer a ramp back into the
nutritional mainstream that just opens
up a slightly more Health compatible
dietary pattern for people in that
situation so
that was a long detour but but that's
where I'm at with the carnivore diet
since we since we ended up there yeah
and to be clear I was just using
carnivore as an example like yeah I'm
more more just talking about the General
Dynamic of when like messaging about a
particular topic outweighs counter
messaging like 10 to 1 or 100 to one and
it's a great example of that and and for
a lot of those like like Niche things
that either don't have much evidence
supporting them or are like pretty
contradicted by the evidence in most
contexts
um yeah like the people the people
pushing them forward pushing those ideas
forward push those ideas forward with
with a level of frequency and regularity
that is that far exceeds uh the counter
messaging like against those things and
so yeah like that that does like that
that is just like a media Dynamic that
makes those ideas become more appealing
to people who initially found a little
appeal in them in the first place yeah
and another example is with seed oil
alarmists like oh yeah yeah I've seen a
number of people who are like so you're
you're this uh you know regular Eater of
seed oils if your argument is as
compelling as mine how come you haven't
matched my content one for one and it's
like because I can't make my whole life
be about seed oils being nice like like
you have literally dedicated the
entirety of your personality to saying
that seed oils are harmful and I cannot
match that because there's no will and
I'd have to like
stop doing literally everything else I
do yeah and it's another example where
it's like I mean I could make a very
very strong argument against that but I
I can't force myself to do that on a
daily basis yeah you're going to make it
once or twice uh I I mean I I think this
is
um
this could be a weakness in our general
content approach where what we like to
do is find a topic and say hey I'm going
to write a very long very thorough piece
on this one topic to to basically cover
it and then if questions come up ah just
just link it back to this single
comprehensive resource
um which like I think is a good way to
go about it but ultimately ultimately I
do think it probably
diminishes our perceived expertise on
those topics
um because yeah like people people will
just naturally be perceived as more of
an expert on the topics they talk about
all the time
um yeah and so yeah like it's I don't
know it's it's weird it's weird I I do
think I do think social media is making
it more difficult to be a generalist
like I I think that a lot of the
Dynamics in play really strongly
incentivize picking one topic that you
really just hit your wagon to and talk
about all the time yeah um which I don't
know probably isn't ideal yeah I agree
um so yeah we've kind of covered why
these types of arguments uh are so
appealing and one thing that that I
should probably mention as well is the
fact that a lot of these arguments in
the fitness space just promote a false
sense of self-efficacy so they basically
say here is a thing that you can
manipulate very effectively and really
change your health and wellness or
Fitness level and in a lot of cases some
of these like
science adjacent or kind of like
pseudoscientific claims really lean into
that because like like all the other
stuff we mentioned it just feels good
when someone says here is a thing you
can do right now that is going to help
you take control of your health and
wellness that feels good and the reality
is if we had that many kind of silver
bullets sitting around uh
the science would look a lot different
right I mean we don't have these
Paradigm shifting interventions every
other day in science yeah uh so a good
example of that is um
we've talked about a couple examples
already of things that are floating
around
um uh but I I sat down in the sauna the
other day I mentioned that I really like
sauna bathing on the show
and uh somebody was already in the sauna
at really really nice person uh you know
and so like I didn't like say anything I
didn't take the wind out of his sails I
was just really polite and friendly but
like as as I sat down he just kind of
announces to the room like hey good on
us uh we just lowered our risk of dying
by 27 percent
that's that's a large effect yeah and uh
and like I know the research he's
referring to I know this statistical
model he's referring to from that paper
I know
the the more nuanced interpretation
which guess what doesn't say that if you
just sit down in that room on a Tuesday
you are now 20 you know whatever
percentage less likely to die I I knew
all those things in my head
um but I just was like oh wow that's
that's awesome cool because like it
doesn't when someone is doing things
that are neutral deposited for their
health and they feel really positive
about them there is nothing beneficial
about taking the wind out of their sails
uh and yeah so I just wasn't interested
in that but but you can see how these
messages that seem scientific you're
like dude this is from like a paper in
Finland and they do good science in
Finland and uh yeah 27 and
you know you can see how that that sense
of self-efficacy is a really powerful
thing even if it's oversimplified to the
point of no longer being true yeah uh so
areas where we see this like man I did a
study on cold exposure during my PhD
people have been going crazy with cold
exposure lately with pseudo-scientific
claims that seem sciency and they're
just way overblown same thing like I
said with sauna
um even just like I mean I've seen
people talking about like man we know
from science on mice that melatonin
plummets your testosterone levels but we
know from science on humans it doesn't
like that's been looked at yeah it just
doesn't but you'll still see on these
like science channels dude stay away
from melatonin your testosterone is
going to plummet that's simply not true
same thing we've talked about on the
show cooling gloves being super
ergogenic they're not like they simply
are not that's a that's a different
context though it is but
I mean
but it it's it's been popularized on big
channels that purport to say we do
science here yeah yeah so I mean it I
think it falls under the umbrella
yeah I I with that one though like you
you very much could point to a study
like a what appears on the surface to be
a high quality longitudinal human
intervention taking the measurements
you'd want to see pre and post guess
what the cooling glove looked incredible
uh but with with the caveat being no one
has really replicated those results
um and uh maybe maybe there were some
conflicts of interest uh in that
particular paper but but yeah like I
I I'm I'm I'm more I'm more sympathetic
to that one because like there there is
a paper that you could point to where
like the
um
like the the mo the most intuitive and
fairest explanation of that paper is
that cooling gloves are are incredible
yeah I guess I I'm a little bit less
charitable about uh four things that
have been
I mean it's not the only study to look
at Palm Cooling
I do like you you went through a number
of related studies right yeah so so that
the single Paper I believe had either
three or four trials detailed uh in the
paper and there were I believe two acute
studies and two longitudinal studies uh
in like like detailed in that single
Paper
um and the acute studies also reported
larger magnitudes of effects than other
acute studies performed with cooling
gloves I don't think there are other
longitudinal studies on like the the
effects of of using a cooling glove
during training over time so yeah I mean
I I'm I'm I'm sympathetic to someone who
sees that and it's like well this this
is what the longitudinal data says and
there's not much to contradict it
um
but I I am still uh intensely skeptical
of the results reported in that study
you know that's an unintentional but
very good segue uh because the next
point I wanted to make here is that this
stuff isn't just in the like industry
world and the social media world but I
mentioned that you know faulty claims
and kind of just low quality content is
it's getting worse not better that also
in my opinion applies to the published
scientific research
um you know there are still people
pushing some really weird theories in
the published literature and uh we
actually there's a quote uh by Stu
Phillips within the the mass Facebook
group uh he said that the ratio of BS to
evidence-based science has increased
dramatically in the last decade and now
there are no barriers to publishing
anything every piece of data will find a
home and I thought that was a really
insightful observation because with the
proliferate I mean the journals are just
popping up like crazy they're everywhere
there are a lot of journals out there
that will gladly accept a thousand
dollars to publish whatever you'd like
um at the very same time
that the the government put out their
list of like the The Dirty Dozen 12
influencer put it 12 influencers doing
the most harm with misinformation one of
them was publishing a paper on those
topics within a journal was that the
Mercola vitamin D in covid paper yeah
yeah within a journal that is
I mean we cover it in Mass all the time
it's a real Journal it's a real journal
the impact factor is high and uh yeah
it's kind of one of those things about
the Dynamics of publishing is that uh
there are enough journals out there
we've talked how you know it's kind of
like uh
you just rinse and repeat right so you
send a paper out to a journal uh the the
reviewers say no this is low quality
work it's not rigorous we cannot accept
it you say okay
I'll go somewhere else and you try again
and again and again and again and again
and then ultimately if you really just
want a link to say hey my thoughts are
actually published science that counts
eventually you can find a journal that's
just completely
predatory in nature and just say I'm
just going to give you 300 bucks just
publish this yeah give me a DOI and a
hyperlink so I can send it out so the
Dynamics of publishing and then you can
launder it by if you want to talk about
it again now it's no longer a novel
infringe idea in the literature it's
it's been published before and so now
you can cite that prior paper and it
looks like you're building upon other
work in on like a well-established topic
and especially with a blinded peer
review
like there's no reason for the reviewers
to know you're just citing to your own
[ __ ] that you publish in a predatory
Journal because no one else could take
it yeah and you know a lot of people
will hear that and they'll say like yeah
I'm sure there's some Bad actors out
there who are just you know they they
have an idea that they're really driven
to get out to the world and and they
want to uh maliciously have it
masquerading as science so they do this
but like
it's not even that so like I I was at a
conference like a reputable conference
uh put on by a reputable organization
involved in science and academics and
there was a presentation about how to
write or publish and
this is an interesting thing because
like uh they basically said listen every
set of data has a home uh some of those
homes are huts and some are Mansions uh
but basically what they're saying is
like whatever you're trying to publish
you can find a journal and this wasn't
saying like oh my God I'm lamenting the
state of the literature this is such a
bad thing this was career advice
keep trying get it somewhere yeah for
your career right and so like it was
really interesting because when I heard
that statement it was kind of framed as
like hey your career is going to be just
fine because whatever you're working on
you will be able to get it published if
you try hard enough and my initial
response was like I am hearing that in a
very different light like I don't think
that's necessarily a good thing like
uh yeah it kind of blurs the line
between what is the purpose of doing
this research is it to get it published
for career related purposes or is it
because
this is a meaningful finding that ought
to be shared with the world because of
its importance
um
and you know I've even been through some
academic talks where people talk
strategically about you know in the peer
review process you submit a paper the
reviewers make comments they send it
back I've been through academic talks
where they talk specifically about how
to appease reviewers and kind of
Leverage psychology and Logistics to
make it such that they are going to
review your revision much more favorably
uh which again is it's kind of turning
it into a bit of a game rather than well
the whole purpose here is to make sure
that we're you know vetting these ideas
to and to make certain that they are
robust and impactful and important
um yeah there's these weird kind of
because of the way the incentives are
aligned it's like
there's a difference between like
disseminating important information and
getting a thing published yeah and so
yeah I think whether you're looking at
the stuff on Instagram and Twitter or
you're looking at the stuff in
peer-reviewed journals like I said I
just think this idea of kind of faulty
ideas floating around and getting
popularized is like I said probably
getting worse rather than better yeah I
I agree with all of that
um
so I just just to add a little bit to
that I I think that there is a whole a
whole genre a whole world of information
that gets disseminated both by like
influencers on social media and in
published research that just just like
broadly follows the theme of assuming
and extrapolating uh logic longitudinal
outcomes from acute measures that have
not been validated for uh uh predicting
longitudinal outcomes so uh is one thing
we've mentioned on this episode already
is
um people assuming that that EMG data
directly tells you about hypertrophy
that if you do two exercises and one of
them leads to higher mean or Peak EMG
readings for the Target muscle uh that
exercise will necessarily lead to more
hypertrophy over time
and the thing is that may or may not be
true and we don't know because it's
never been studied
um to to establish that you would need
at least a study where
um
you know you you pick two exercises that
at least on the surface seem like they
should have like similar hypertrophic
effects
um you get some EMG data at Baseline see
which one does lead to higher mean or
Peak EMG readings uh and then you do a
longitudinal study like over eight weeks
12 weeks 16 weeks whatever look to see
like do these two exercises lead to
differences in hypertrophy and if so uh
did the one that that led to larger EMG
readings lead to more hypertrophy
um like that that's the type of study
you would need to do and and that would
just be step one
um because you know it could be that
there's some characteristic of the
exercise that makes it more effective
for hypertrophy that also makes it more
like that also leads to a larger EMG
reading
um but you know that that may not
necessarily be a generalizable thing
like it could just be like a length
dependent thing maybe you get like a
higher EMG reading uh if a muscle is in
a length in state but like like yeah
maybe the EMG isn't that important maybe
it is just training the muscle in a
length and state so then you would need
to probe that that concept a little bit
more like let's try another set of
exercises that uh screens out potential
confounders in that first set so like
you would probably need uh at least like
four or five uh like longitudinal
validation studies on this idea to see
is this a valid proxy measure for
predicting longitudinal outcomes
and like we don't even have one like
that that research just doesn't exist
yet
um but there's a lot of social media
content that's just like either hey
here's this study that looked at EMG and
I'm going to make longitudinal
inferences from the study or much more
infuriatingly hey I bought an EMG unit
and I did uh like four triceps exercises
uh and and monitored my EMG during all
three of the or all four of those
exercises and like this was the one that
for me led to higher led to the highest
triceps EMG and therefore all of you
should be doing this like that's that's
even a step lower
um but yeah like that that stuff uh gets
bandied about on social media all the
time and there there are still plenty of
scientific studies where like I I like
like what one of the Dynamics in
research is like
you're supposed to kind of like sell the
reviewers and then the readers on like
why your research is important
um
and I mean for for EMG studies uh you
know the the
honest answer for for a lot of them like
there are certainly like disease States
and like neuromuscular stuff where EMG
is very important but like in terms of
hey we're gonna recruit healthy young
people and just have them do like six
hamstrings exercises and measure EMG
um like the actual import of that study
is just hey now we know the EMG values
for these six exercises which
what can you do with that I don't know
so when you're trying to sell it you
just kind of like imply ah and we
suspect that this will uh be suggestive
of like hypertrophy down the line or
whatever so like that that is an idea
that is still like pretty popular in
research and I think that's one of the
reasons why people pick it up and and
run with it on social media
um but yeah that's an example of taking
an acute proxy measure and assuming that
it's going to generalize to longitudinal
results but there's a lot of uh there
are a lot of examples in this General
theme so uh like like recovery
modalities for instance like if uh if
something helps you recover in 48 hours
from a training session versus 72 hours
um you know the the research will often
say like hey this improved recovery and
so like ah people will be able to train
more train harder get better results uh
and that's often how it's presented uh
you know in in Industry as well and
honestly I've probably done that as well
um or at least not uh presented stuff
like that with as much caution as I
probably should but I mean again
ultimately we don't know
um and it it probably depends on like
the mechanism of action as well like you
can't necessarily assume that just
because something leads to slightly
faster recovery it's necessarily going
to lead to better gains
um so like for example uh you know we
talked about high doses of NSAIDs
um last episode I believe we've talked
about uh uh ice bathing and the negative
effects that can have on hypertrophy
both of those things do improve markers
of recovery like if you take a high dose
of NSAIDs immediately before or
immediately after a session
um like your your Force output 24 48
hours after this after the session will
probably be a little bit higher uh
creating kinase levels probably a little
bit lower soreness a little bit lower
but in both of those cases
um recovery is better longitudinally it
it actually might have negative effects
on hypertrophy and so yeah like like
some things that improve recovery might
help gains over time some might have a
neutral effect some might actually
hinder you because they're uh uh leading
to what is perceived to be faster
recovery because they're uh like tamping
down on the inflammatory response you
actually need for muscle Remodeling and
adaptation
um another example of that is like there
are still like not certainly not as many
as there used to be but there are still
some studies that uh will basically try
a supplement or try some sort of like
training intervention
um and just look at acute effects on
testosterone and growth hormone and just
assume that if something causes like a
five percent bump in acute testosterone
response or like a 10 bump in acute
growth hormone response it's necessarily
going to lead to more hypertrophy like
that gets published in the research that
gets disseminated on social media
um
there's there's not like the the
longitudinal evidence for that is uh
somewhere between weak and fully
debunked
um depend depending who you ask I I'm in
the camp that I don't think that the
hormone hypothesis is fully debunked but
that's a that's a methodological
question for another day I'd say it's 70
of the way debunked
um another example is uh like a lot of
research on like warm-up protocols and a
lot of research on supplements looks at
performance during a single training
session so you know does taking this
supplement or doing this particular
warm-up protocol uh help you complete
yeah three four five more reps over
three or four sets of an exercise if it
does if it acutely improves performance
it's going to lead to more hypertrophy
larger strength gains that is an
assumption that is made in the
literature all the time that is an
assumption that makes it onto social
media that a lot of Industry experts
will uh sign off on
um and yeah like in a lot of cases like
that stuff is unproven so I I think
there maybe people are thinking about
creatine because like creatine does
acutely improve performance to some
extent and also leads to larger gains
over time and I think I think people
just kind of get it in their head that
like oh well if we see similar acute
effects to creatine we should probably
see similar longitudinal effects
um and like oftentimes we don't so uh uh
sodium bicarbonate is an example of
something that acutely improves strength
endurance performance like rep
performance during a single session uh
there are a couple longitudinal studies
on it now doesn't seem to improve
results over time uh caffeine is another
one like this this was a wild one to me
like there's so much caffeine research
but we didn't get our first longitudinal
study on it until like what like 18
months ago or something
um but yeah there's like what one or two
longitudinal caffeine studies now uh
yeah acutely improved performance
doesn't seem to improve gains over time
uh and then for just like another
example of extrapolation not necessarily
extrapolating acute results to
longitudinal results but just general
extrapolation
um a lot of the ideas that that blow up
and get popular and and I'll note like
generally this stuff is better in the
research
um but in terms of where things are
taken on social media uh there there
will be a study that either just uses
like cell culture research where you
culture some cells uh expose them to
some particular molecule or chemical in
some particular concentration and just
look at the effects like within those
cells or
um you know you you've bred a strain of
mutant mice that have like a particular
Gene added or deletion to have a
particular condition and then you give
them like massive doses of a particular
drug supplement whatever and then look
at the effects and you know you might
see some really striking results in that
type of research and then people take
that and say oh yeah so uh you as a
human
um not in a Petri dish and not of a a
mouse bread to have like a particular
like genetic condition uh yeah you're
you're definitely going to see these
effects um yeah the dose you'll be
taking for this thing will lead to
concentrations within your cells that
are like 50 times lower than what was
used in the cell culture research but
yeah like you'll you'll see the same
[ __ ]
um like I said generally that stuff's
not quite as bad in research like basic
science researchers uh in by basic
science researchers I mean not like like
people who aren't doing like
translational research where you're not
doing interventions on humans that are
meant to kind of be applied to a lot of
humans like basic science is just like
bench work cell culture stuff uh like
like rodent studies where where you're
just kind of really trying to understand
basic physiologies mechanisms stuff like
that uh folks who do that type of
research it's rare or to see someone say
like oh yeah we culture these myo tubes
and uh this uh this plant extract at
this concentration led to a four-fold
increase in muscle protein synthesis and
therefore uh humans should go out and
buy this and take it like the the
researchers in that area tend to tend to
be uh quite cautious but in terms of
once that stuff makes it onto social
media a lot of that Nuance is lost and
it's just assumed like yeah we can we
can extrapolate the hell out of this
um so yeah there's there's a ton of that
just just either extrapolating from
basic science research to uh uh
assumptions of longitudinal translation
in in humans or uh just acute studies
that are that people hope are a proxy
for whatever longitudinal outcome they
want without the validation research
done to verify that those acute
variables are actually like valid strong
predictors of whatever longitudinal
outcome you're you're interested in
yeah I think you pointed out a really
interesting dichotomy there
um about research which is that if you
are a basic researcher who's doing more
mechanistic work
the
understanding the assumption is if you
even try to extrapolate this you're
going to make a fool of yourself so like
in their papers
who is very way less common to see those
kinds of ambitious
uh attempts to extrapolate into clinical
outcomes right they'll say hey here's a
starting point somebody picked this up
and we'll run with it
um through more research not straight to
application but um
there is that kind of Middle Ground
where it's like oh well we're doing
human trials but we're talking about
stuff that happens over eight hours here
right yeah and a lot of times people say
well no but you got to make this thing
interesting you got to spice it up tell
me what it really means because nobody
really cares about what happens over
these eight hours they want to know
what's going to happen over the next
eight months and so there's almost this
kind of implied pressure when you're
doing human trials that aren't
longitudinal to say yeah but tell me
what what will be the longitudinal
outcome of applying this uh so it's an
interesting Divergence about the kind of
different pressures that different types
of researchers are under when it comes
to you know should I try to really sell
this as being a useful idea or am I
gonna just make an ass to myself if I
try to do that yeah
um were you gonna say something yeah I I
was just going to say like I think
that's an example where
the incentives are kind of [ __ ]
because I I think if you I I think if
you pulled a thousand researchers who do
a lot of acute human studies in exercise
physiology I think
950 of them or more would say like yeah
no like you shouldn't you shouldn't
extrapolate that stuff like a lot of
these proxy measures haven't been
validated for for predicting
longitudinal outcomes like I think they
would sign off on that and then if you
pulled up their publication history that
those aren't the behaviors you would see
yeah and I think there's an extremely
good reason for that and that is I mean
ultimately I mean ultimately like it's
it's a competitive game you know like
you you have to get your stuff published
um and hopefully in in pretty good
journals for hiring for career
advancement for getting tenure Etc
um and it's one of those things where
like
if everyone you're competing against for
the finite publication slots and good
journals kinda does that stuff too like
you kind of have to as well otherwise
you are you are telling the section
editors and you're telling the reviewers
hey like my my research just like isn't
as important and impactful as all of
this other research
um even though like all of that other
research is of just like a similar level
of import and impact
um but yeah so if if if everyone else is
like [ __ ] well I kind I kind of got to
play this game then
you either have to play the game too or
just like suffer a negative career
repercussions for standing true to your
beliefs which like I don't know I'm sure
you could make a an interesting ethical
argument that that maybe you should do
that
um but ultimately like
I don't know man
like you you
you're responding to the same incentives
that everyone else is uh and I I think
at the end of the day once you've
gone all the way through [ __ ] grad
school and gotten your PhD and then it's
just like well I'm this pot committed
um and here's this here's this this tiny
little thing I have to do we're like on
some of my papers I have to add a little
paragraph that I don't necessarily agree
with completely but I'm I'm so deep in
and that is going to have like a
tangible impact on like my future
employment situation
I think like almost a hundred percent of
people have a very easy time
rationalizing that to themselves
um
and yeah it's it's one of those things
where I think if if there was just kind
of like a uh
if if there was like more cooperation
where you could just get everyone
together and everyone collectively agree
hey we're not gonna do this anymore
we're not gonna play this game none of
us feel good about it it could just stop
but like it's not gonna happen so uh
yeah you you got you got to play the
game everyone else is playing and then
even if you were hypothetically to get
that to happen which it won't uh then
you run into the issue where yeah you
know you've got people within a field
who are fighting over a particular piece
of the pie
but they're not just trying to convince
reviewers and editors that what they're
doing is interesting and impactful
they're trying to also convince funding
bodies who dish out the money and they
that is also true yeah they decide how
big that piece of the pie is yeah and so
if for example everyone doing you know
exercise and nutrition research said hey
we're really going to start you know
understating the impact of our findings
and really kind of keeping it low-key I
would say accurately stating but sure
but you know what I mean relative to the
current situation yeah directionally
compared to where we're at now if we
started really kind of you know
tempering some of those perspectives a
little bit then you might find a
situation where it's just no one in the
fields getting funded anymore yeah not
literally no one but the piece of the
pie shrinks and everyone looks around
and say and says I think we shouldn't
have made that pact yeah yeah so it the
incentives are really challenging it
when it comes to that particular topic
all right so I think that does it for
this particular episode uh once again
today is November 21st as you're
listening to this uh the mass Black
Friday sale has officially begun it's
only going to last from the 21st through
the 28th so if you want to get the best
price of the year and you want to
support charity be sure to check that
out at strongerbyscience.com mass as
always thanks so much for joining us we
hope you have a fantastic Thanksgiving
if you happen to celebrate and we'll be
back soon with another episode
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules we
hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
can sign up for the free newsletter at
strongerbyscience.com newsletter or just
go to the stronger by science homepage
and click the free programs button at
the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our Facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional once again thank you for
listening and we will be back soon with
another episode of The Stronger by
science podcast
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]